uh memeology made a new video
and it's actually about youtube so let's
check this out
sure shout out to bemology
youtube ceo susan wojcicki promises
rapper juice world
artificial growth for his youtube
channel
keemstar was talking about this
yesterday too actually she does this
during a no jumper vlog
no what's no jumper whoa wait a minute
so susan will jiggy oh she's
yeah yeah oh yeah was on no jumper
hosted by adam 22 adam grand mason a man
who has
been plagued with allegations of sexual
assault and when i say allegations and
plagued i mean
not a gut not a chris hardwick not a guy
who's got one angry ex-girlfriend i mean
literally plagued
with assault allegations allegations of
filming women without their consent
allegations of
straight-up women susan wojcicki just
hopped on his thing right
now is this the same adam 22 that hopped
in our chat and you told him to go [ __ ]
his mother basically she beat it
yeah basically and he left he left with
his [ __ ] tailbone
taking a million subs and get the [ __ ]
out of here yeah [ __ ]
you ain't your bandana uh here we go
oh gee you know how we spoke about
getting your subscribers off yeah
she's the big boss of adults so this has
been real
i know how can we help you
we're you're so talented we gotta get
your subscriber numbers
i hate there's nothing more annoying
and shrill and transparent in the world
than a pandering woman i'm sorry but
they when they like oh my god i love the
hip-hop
you're so talented you don't
stop pretending like you operate
anywhere within a world the same world
as juice world
let's just stop susan it's like when
laura ingram
who's trying to be like white women are
horrible at that when they try to be
like
how tap jesus what's going on hey
rockefeller am i right i'm just like
stop white women
stop it so this is her saying
you're so talented we gotta get your
subscriber
how are you going to make it happen
susan you mean us who have to work
really really hard and eat 90 day bands
all the time
just to get the little penance that we
have and it's it's just maybe i'm
maybe i'm [ __ ] up maybe i'm putting my
little tinfoil hat on i don't want to
make accusations here right but like
if you're able to make good things
happen to people
on this platform uh oh and give them
bonuses and subscribers and and open up
the floodgates for them then it's not
outside the realm of possibility for me
to assume
that you can also do the opposite of
that that you can dial people back
and throttle them and choke them a
little bit just saying
way up he's right there we're gonna make
it happen
all right right around here we're here
we're here for you however we can you
have no idea
as long as you're pushing drug use and
degeneracy to kids
uh promiscuous sex things of that nature
we will put you at the top page you have
no idea we would love
to make sure as long as you got those
kids drinking lean
and spending money on jordan's you have
our support
but if you tell people to get married
and to avoid drugs and alcohol
and to have a nice life and to maybe
build a nice life for yourself
maybe go to church on sunday you're
[ __ ] out of here bud
you're out of here
[Music]
[Applause]
uh must be nice to be assured by the ceo
herself that your channel will grow
i know you're dude i love you guys
so proud of this community i'm so proud
of you i love that meme
at the end of every video about youtube
from the rewind
he's just a [ __ ] i like i like
memeology because it's not look
there are i'm not going to pretend like
there aren't
thousands of people out there making
similar videos to memeology with the
same exact message
the reason why memology is good at it is
because he knows how to make propaganda
you have to make something
that hits people it has to be funny or
it has to have like some themes to it so
you're like all right let's see with
this
this [ __ ] guy so that's why he's
succeeding i think where so many people
are failing
because he takes it's not enough to just
go look what she's doing
and be outraged because everybody's like
all right outraged
get out of here like you have to be
clever and subversive and
like i'm super community like [ __ ] like
that is
why he's succeeding because he knows how
to he knows how to really push the
message
uh trey y here's my monthly allotted
youtube stimulus package two dollars
alex brown you guys are great keep up
the good work five dollars thank you
alex waterman five bucks
uh robbie don't care he made a complete
ass of himself this is about oh and he
made a complete ass of himself on red
elephants yesterday you could tell vince
was embarrassed
yeah owen was on red elephants yesterday
apparently and i heard it was
i heard one of the best quotes from that
was
uh you got to get married vince is like
i am married he's like all right you got
to start having kids
this is like i have kids he doesn't know
anything about vince like
like this is just classic owen where
it's like i don't
i'm not even gonna bother to learn
anything about you you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you you're lucky i'm here
like that attitude like royce and i will
go on a podcast that has
20 listeners because they support us and
we're like well of course we got your
back
we actually will go and take a little
time
and learn a thing or two about the guy
whose show we're going on
so that they can feel good in our
exchange with them and they can go oh
cool he knows who i am you watch some of
my stuff
owen has no point of reference